eine solche die die ganze welt klagt
deren verbreitung medien quasi live in
die ganze welt übertragen
das gab es noch nicht in der geschichte
der menschheit das ist elementar
existenziell und es macht angst
es ist eine prüfung für jeden einzelnen
für das offene europa für die welt
corona ändert alles nicht nur in italien
das still steht auch bei uns
ob die politik zu früh oder zu spät
gehandelt hat ob diese oder jene
maßnahme richtig oder falsch war
ob es um profilierung oder echte
lösungen ging das werden wir aus dem
monaten wissen aber was wir jetzt schon
wissen kindisches auf andere zeigen wie
trump es vormacht hilft nicht das ist
die plumpe show eines nervösen
wahlkämpfers dass populisten die schuld
immer bei anderen suchen das sich
spalten jetzt europa und großbritannien
das ist nicht neu aber im fall corona
ist es besonders widerwärtig nein es
braucht jetzt keine schuldzuweisungen es
braucht die bereitschaft das leben zu
verlangsamen um die überforderung
unseres gesundheitswesens zu verhindern
es braucht verzicht innehalten nicht nur
um unsere eigenen gesundheit willen
sondern vor allem um andere schwächeren
ältere zu schützen
es braucht eigene verantwortung statt
egoismus gemeinsinn stadt grenzziehungen
geduld stadt beschleunigen
mir geht in diesen tagen einen roman
durch den kopf den wir in der schulzeit
gelesen haben die pest von albert camus
eine stadt am meer wird gelähmt von
einer unheimlichen solche ein arzt
kämpft gegen alle widrigkeiten und
ziemlich allein gegen die krankheit
das leitet ihn eine fast absurd
erscheinende hoffnung und
mitmenschlichkeit corona ist nicht die
pest aber es ist eine bewährungsprobe
für unser miteinander